Hello.
I look so small!
I look so tiny!
I look so tiny.
I'm just searching up some stuff no face hugger asset is there is there one of
those that I can get hold on me don't be funny if I could do that sorry that's
boomy playing with this toy I like put up a little feather bell toy and oops I
didn't mean to press that no and um he like he likes it a lot he'll like run
off to it and then like smack it and then run away he's really enjoying
himself I'm glad what is I doing I forget I'm throwing some freckles on
brother yep sorry I need to uh alter my character more than I already have
that's too big there you go oh that's what I was gonna do I was gonna turn up
my physics a little bit cuz there we go now I have better mouth tracking hello
hi he's been bulking I have rena on my lap Fia is in bed in the bed on her bed
on the ground because this morning when I went to the bathroom and I put her on
the couch she managed to roll off the couch and fall on the floor I yeah and I
was really mortified I was like crying cuz I'm like what if something happened
to you so I was really worried but she's fine but she like I just like I'm
sitting I you know I'm my own business sitting on the toilet you know I'm like
that Elmo get boomie can you stop making so much noise and try and tell
story and I I'm like that Elmo gif like on the toilet just like and then I just
hear a thump and I'm like did boomie run into something and then I get up
plus a toilet and Fia's just like on the floor then I'm like thank you thank you
for the toilet super yeah she's moving I generally don't know how she rolled
cuz she was like pretty stationary so she literally wiggled off the couch and
I'm like what are you doing um I'm just making my waiting rooms for what's it
called making my waiting rooms making my way downtown for the week cuz I
haven't done that yet and then a girl is I don't really take all that seriously
so it's fine I guess I can tweet I usually don't really bother tweeting if
I'm live for the farming stuff so yeah that's fine I don't really care about
tweeting about the gorilla too much if people want to come they find they they
don't have ways they have no they have they they've jorked the notification
bill boomi's having the time of his life behind me oh my gosh I almost had I'm
almost at a hundred videos what the heck that's so cool I've never made a hundred
videos in my life my head is falling out of the blanket that's fine okay I need a
post my new short there's $1 in during the stream thanks um notification
bill in the rest of the time oh man oh well I'm glad you can make this that's
good yeah you get three streams today madlad yeah I got 14k I'm so happy so
close to 15k she be cute no you know you link yeah I just like streaming and
then I have all my stuff done so like I've already recorded some shorts like
my shorts are kind of like backlogged right now because they're like waiting
on editors to finish other shorts I'm trying to think of projects to do in
the meantime I might try to record a song cover for Stacy's mom because it's
like I don't really I'm like my growth is stagnated so like I'll just I'll just
like acknowledge that like I'm not performing as well as I want to be and
so I'm just trying to come up with ways to like you know you know have some
grab people's attention and just kind of have them want to stick around and
hang out cuz I realized I just I like I do a lot more streaming and gaming like I
don't do a lot of cute girls doing cute things stuff um and I'm wondering if I
should do more of that I don't know I don't know parody version oh no the real
like a real cover of Stacy's mom a parody would be funny though
hi let me continue I didn't get a lot of sleep last night I'm running on like
maybe four hours again um but I'm just like I'm pretty wide awake so my back
hurts um I'm why don't make yeah I was in the dark
Ed will stream wait I need I need to see my schedule cuz you guys know I don't
remember anything
sorry I'm telling how much I love Mari and Diems cuz she's wonderful and I
can't wait for our collab with Tomah and Chai this week where is my manager
sends my schedule in my discord so I have to I have to look at it oh hi Mari
I was thinking Amy's most popular videos of shorts about vTubing um I actually
already recorded shorts like that again every all my shorts are on backlog and
so like I've already recorded three scripted shorts to have to do with v
tubing stuff hopefully they go they pop off but I'll be honest with you I feel
like there's other like there's very like I know what people like I I've
analyzed I've hyper I've hyper analyzed with my chism um the vTubing vTubing
appeals to vTubers and Amy hits all of those boxes I do not and there are
reasons for that one I just don't again I'm not I'm not cute girl doing cute
things I'm kind of just like raging bro and not so many people wanna bro some
people just want like cute dainty feminine energy I have my moments where
I do that and then I'm brown and you might think that's not a factor but
definitely is um I have a deeper voice and yes I know Amy has shown her deeper
voice but she mostly voice acts and her voice acting voice is very cute and I
also yes hags are in demand but not as much as people think so like I'm just
analyzing and then she's has she's consistent consistency is key that's
actually one of my shorts is about is consistency she's extremely consistent
and puts out new content all the time I'm learning a lot from her she's been a
content creator for a lot longer than I have and very successful so I've I've
um I've definitely been taking notes I want Amy does so that I can kind of
just follow her example and just improve my own content because she's a very good
role model to me my little sister and then like there's those cases that's
like my personality just might not be appealing to people and I can't really
do anything about that um yeah that's those are just my observations and then
it doesn't help that like that people uh get a wrong idea about me because of
out of context clips so it's it's kind of amusing I'm pretty sure a lot of
people just dislike who I am because of that one clipper just spamming
everything on a certain basket weaving board about my negative opinion on the
some male vtubers
Keejibut having a boy personality she means a cute girl so I know she does
definitely cute girls doing cute things usually hits hard with the shorts
exactly um again I have been working on those but again it's kind of frustrating
because I wish we had more editors that were more on top of things some editors
go super fast some of them go super slow I love that don't talk don't get me
wrong I appreciate the editors and all the work they do because editing shorts
isn't as his work and that's why we pay him for it but I minor minor I think last
in line so I don't even know when mine are coming out but don't let this deter you
we all love you so much you care about you a lot hit so many me she's as
yourself so every moment says yeah yeah she's she's guiding me a lot a lot of my
gen mates give me a lot of advice I'm gonna ask for it strong especially I
have a I should have an ASMR video coming out sometime today and I'm I'm gonna
ask for another one I'm also just learning again I have never been a
full-time content creator I've only ever but it's been like a hobby streamer so
learning what people like and what they want more of like long-form content
besides just streaming like like ASMR's and stuff is it's an experience and so
I'm just like okay you guys want more of this I'm gonna work I'm gonna get more
of this but I need to wait on other people so I can do more of this because
I have like scriptwriters and that's why I'm also trying to fall in follow
Amy's example just write my own scripts cuz sometimes it can take a while yeah
those are Roblox collab also include harem no maybe I don't know I don't know
if you guys could be on there I don't know I guess I don't play Roblox Mari
is showing me everything I realized really the baby the group when it comes
to content creation it's actually true I have the least amount of content
creation um out of everybody everybody has been doing it a lot longer than I
have Strani might say oh you have more V2 me experience but not by a much and
actually now that actually really just put things in perspective for me because
I do have the least amount of it I've literally it's almost been a wow actually
that thank you for pointing that out to me because all the other girls have been
around a lot longer than I have um god damn but yeah no I bingo card I don't
know what is there do people do that guys I've never done a Roblox collab or
video or anything well let me pop out chat so I can see it while I make the
waiting rooms cuz I still haven't done that yet okay I gotta do the doom
maternal settings doom okay we are playing the game for real this time I
don't know what a caption any of my freaking videos to be honest with you
half the time I'm just like whatever I don't you know sipa happy labor day she
be some oh hey oh call me some time oh my gosh um who is cozy bunny hello I am
she be cotton them if you are new here welcome I'm just I'm a dork I'm a girl
failure hi I'm literally Jen alpha so I love Roblox no like I've never really and
like don't think like Roblox is after my time cuz it's not like Roblox has been
around for a while I just don't I've just never played it I just never played it
change this thumbnail to the real doom thumbnail although it says part two it's
not really part two but that's what my manager made and I didn't feel like
correcting him so what day is this on it's on Tuesday unit okay that's when I
put at 6 p.m. cuz I have a doctor's appointment for Fia they have to take
her to at 3 30 6 p.m. 6 p.m.
just like how some yeah yeah no you didn't miss anything I'm just chatting
Roblox is older than you what huh how old is Roblox wait how old is Roblox
Mari that doesn't sound right you're making it sound like you're
Mari oh my god anyways she's not she guys she is of age I swear Mari oh
frick I messed up I accidentally double clicked edit okay I think that looks
alright did I do that okay you know it's fine did I mess up yeah because Roblox
came out like 18 years ago why are you saying then Mari is my manager do you
guys think Mari is my manager Roblox as the company is older okay what's the
Roblox company you're still incorrect you're still wrong I'm pretty sure you're
still wrong Mari is my fourth pet Mari is my
13th reason why okay okay holo cure let me just use this or use the setting I
don't know what holo care is about
we I'm a cute girl fighting off things I don't know
she's oh my god Mari boomie can you move your Bob you can just lay there I kept
trying to hang up the whiteboard that you guys got me and it kept falling off of
the wall and then it ripped the paint off the wall and I'm like what when we
don't rub against it you're gonna knock it down so I just have it perched on my
cats litter box right now when we don't jump behind there bro if you knock this
down and it scares you I'm gonna laugh at you because then you deserve it no I
got mail it was no it's cuz it's supposed to be like drilled into the wall but I
don't want to drill it into the wall not that I couldn't not that it's not
allowed in my apartment I can definitely drill stuff into the wall like you um but
I just I don't feel like having to fix it up when before I leave if I have to
leave soon or something let me see that is on September 4th at the 4 p.m. not
changed thumbnail what do you mean oh yeah and I just I just don't feel like
having to like spat stuff wherever the heck it's called when I leave okay
hood morning good morning um I have some OJ
spackle that's what it is I don't know I call it spat spattle hall of care is a
vampire survivor and the story is the fans for mascots were mind-controls
into finding them whoa whoa whoa let me find faith the holy trinity reuse
settings part twa if I don't beat this boss in five seconds I'm but I can't
type that much I swear to God Mari Mari I'm gonna choke you out much is gonna
say yes mommy
shiny trying to eliminate her I'll be too crazy what um I'll be on Thursday at 4 p.m.
oh did I do the right thumbnail I don't know I don't know if I did the right
thumbnail I did nope I didn't mean to click go live actually definitely yes I
did okay then we got the Roblox collab can I just find the over cut cloud is
actually a little bit why back okay let me just you reuse the golf it Roblox
collab Mari wait Mari smells I should just make that the title um
looks like I dyed my hair blue I did I dyed my hair blue you like it matches my
eyes what should I call the thing
boomie can you stop bothering her boomie stop stop I hear her kissing in the
next freaking room leave her alone oh that snap like hurt my hand cuz I am
pathetic um hello two children no I'm not gonna put that in the title Jesus
Christ
arena this boomie bothering you here let me take care of it I have a gun boomie I
can see your butt under there you think I can't reach you stop bothering me I know
we're not gonna play just dress to impress but that's what my freaking
manager put although I said I said we're doing a variety of games boomie's
honking at me here I'll call it we are doing more than just dress to impress
okay Roblox can you all type your information in the give me your links
where is the can I have all your links I'm on YouTube now you are interesting check out
the girls yes but post your link Mari don't I don't want to type out the whole
thing you got an ad good um check out the girls
popo popo popo
chai Toma Toma keys on and Mari Mari you get to go last I've heard of doors I've
seen a game theory about that and I was actually very interested sorry just
um that actually feels really good I'm turning into an alien Friday 6th at 10
p.m. Eastern time because Mari screams freaking hoping the Roblox bond remains
intact um that that's all depending on a Mari because I know Mari will say some
out of pocket stuff what do I mean accidentally clicked on mail instead of
YouTube hey the last collapse data I want to play overcooked again actually
want to play played up now I'm watching game crumps play played up um the
water as in Marys hands um yeah I'm gonna have to start delete stop deleting I
keep I should just private bonds I keep deleting them instead but thank God for
archive bros actually I have no I have no clue what I'm going to do for this ASMR
stream I'm not gonna lie to you I don't know what triggers I can do
but why is there an exclamation point you're my food delivery person
it's a little vulgar hello hi
she be with the dirt what did you just have a seizure recreate the stream she be
what are you okay do you get kicked in the head if you did that I that's all
right inspired by a door dash meltdown drag the food delivery person sign
and distress the driver from a big no I want to like yell at them I want to be
like you were late you messed up my food I'm beating you up but I just don't know
like what I'm gonna do like I want to I want to be a more aggressive ASMR your
brother did drop that explains a lot anyways and that's at 4 p.m. okay oh my
waiting rooms are up baby you guys know if I bully you it's affectionate POV
listeners a hunk of metal she views a blacksmith where's the blacksmith what's
that from I remember oh wait that's Markiplier I think punching bag ASMR that
would just sound sussy the entire time I don't even I don't even know you shot us
and blended us this past Friday yeah but that wasn't like a real ASMR that was a
meme ASMR not that this one isn't gonna be over so I can keep an eye make sure
she doesn't freaking flip off the couch again like the gymnast she is
oh my god my back
who be what are you scared of there's nothing there he's tweaking against the
little girl
Okay, work hard on your homework, Mari.
No, that won't happen until the cute model, cute funny model, although I can definitely easily do that now and just make my head super big, my body super small, somehow, I wonder, I just thought of something, what if I, I could probably make my head transparent.
And then give my body as an asset to the other girls to use. Do you think Emmy would be safe on the House of Blue if I just gave her my, but she just, she used my head like a booth model body, my body like a booth model body and she stuck her head on my body. That would be so funny. Or like I see, that would be so funny.
That's actually what a hundred, because all I got to do is make my head transparent and then send them the file.
Hi, Bea. Oh, I just want to give you lots of kisses. I can't believe you fucking rolled off the couch. You're silly, you're silly for that. Where are you going?
Feel their cosplaying as me, essentially. Well then imagine, imagine my head on Icy's body. That would be so funny. But like we still have our normal faces. Donate them my worm body.
She likes, she loves kisses and belly scratches so much. She's so happy right now. Oh, wait, maybe, maybe I can turn on the camera. Oh wait, no, it's not plugged in. Oh my God, boomie, where the frick did you come from?
Hi, handsome. Give you a smooch too. What are you doing?
Boomie, are you going to go snuggle with Bea in the bed? Are you going to give her kisses? Oh, she's giving you kisses, boomie, she's sticking your leg. Who wants to snuggle? Nope, never mind, she's biting his leg.
Well, she's trying to. Where's the cat girl? I'm a bunny girl. Ignore the cat ears on my blanket. Cat girls are overrated, you know? Bunny girls are the new cat girl.
Bea going after the sweet boy, boomie. What are you doing, boomie? I'm just, he's like walking around my desk and it's kind of funny because he just like squeezed past my 3DO and Bea's just like trying to grab his leg and it's kind of funny because you know, Bea's just like a blob.
Okay. Are the most what? Excuse me?
Hi. What happened to your nose? Oh, did you bonk your nose when you fell? You have a little red spot.
All right, something, something Elden Ring, right? Is that what we're doing? Is he wrong? No.
Anyways, Elden Ring. My, uh, I don't know how but Fallout New Vegas rearranged my entire desktop on its own accord. I had things in different places and it totally, when I, when I opened it, it just threw everything around.
Did you know in terms of human to chupacompatibility, bunny chupas are the most breedable and compatible with an enemy? Okay. Let me just E-wink. Let me just E-wink. Let me just E-wink.
Oh, echo. How? My boobs. My boobies are so sore.
I need them massaged. Squish-squish-squish-squish-squish-squish-squish-squish-squish-squish-squish.
I don't know why I just they really hurt lately
Must be that I synced up with Emmy
You just want lots of attention, huh?
How about her trying to clap together
Oh
Morning
My pokemon stream I never streamed pokemon. Oh, I mean the smasher pass
And I'm stuck in the void looking at nothing but darkness
I'm dying. I'm dying
Now I internet go out again
help
please
Come back
Oh, baby come back to me come back in my heart. I still believe we were meant to be
I
So many drop frames, uh, I didn't delete the tweet. What the fuck are you talking about?
I'm back
In slow motion in low frames
Uh, I don't know what happened there, but literally my internet goes out
So I had taken off my blah and I had put it on my couch
My internet goes out. I'm like talking to myself and then boomi grabs my bra
and runs off
And just flying around my house with my bra on his head
And I wasn't even able to catch that because literally my internet goes out
Why?
It was so funny. In fact, I actually have to see where he is
I don't even
It's like the
Boomi
Where did you bring my bra to?
She like ran off with it. Oh there it is
My
Raw stared him. He was running around the house my bra on his head
Because it I don't know if he knocked he like tried to smack it because like the strap was hanging
Fiya, can you believe this? Can you believe this guy over here?
Hello
He's just like
Just for real for real. Okay
I got bored doing no go back and do your homework. I don't want you stressing out
Um
You know, yes, I do I can't hold up my back and my shoulders are
help
I can't stop giving fia kisses. She's so cute. I can't kiss her. I gotta kiss the baby
With a little buck teeth sticking out. You look so goofy
You're such a goofy looking cat
Put them on my head they stew
All right fia, can you believe this junk? All right, let's let's uh
Let's uh word Elden Ring go it's gone Elden Ring's just I'm in the void
Oh
Baby, are you coming for the void? I'm
Game capture Elden Ring switch
Nifty it's so fucking loud
I don't even have my headphones in but I can oh my god. Here he goes. Here he goes
He's tweaking. Don't do it again. Don't grab my bra again because I just put it back in the same spot because I'm lazy
What are you doing?
Mr. Mr. Crackhead. No, don't hit Rilakkuma
I have a Rilakkuma plushie in my couch. Don't ask why he but that's he likes to hang out there. I don't I don't question it
I
Can you hear him?
He gets so excited
I
Don't know you could I don't know if you can hear him making noise though. He's he's making noises. It's funny
He's like oh, and then just like smacking it and then running away
All right, I'm pulling my headphones in
Fia are you ready to rumble? I feel like you want to turn around so you can face me so you're not here we go
Is that better for you ma'am?
Yeah
Yeah, Fia's a little tee-fee stick out so it's kind of funny. He's a little bit of an overbite
And she has some googly eyes
She looks like that cat that crunches stuff sometimes, you know the cat that's like black and white
And it's like crunches and it goes
And it's like famous on tiktok. That's what Fia looks like to me
She's nibbling on my hand affectionately. What are you doing? I'm giving you belly rubs. Why are you munching on my arm?
Yeah, crunchy cat Luna. Exactly. That's who she reminds me of
She like looks like that cat sometimes
I can't get my headphones in
You're snorting over
Okay
It was a long road, but we're here
Hold on. Okay, everybody posted their links
Perfect
We love it
I'll grab those later
Wow
Okay, we're not fighting mesmer
I can't do it. I'm not strong enough. I don't have the strength to do it
Um, so we're just gonna go run around do other fun stuff because now we're like at the shadow keep
I'm assuming
If I go this way I can cross over
Yes
Right do I have to beat mesmer to get to this over here?
Yeah, I need to get more scada three
Go to the finger man. Who's the finger man? Is it like me to
Is a lot I haven't really discovered. Oh my god. Uh, oh, there he goes. Let me be tweaking
Uh, okay, so I'll run around a little bit
He's honking, um
How do I
Get across that other bridge. Where is it?
So on this side
It is
She's literally like in a totally different spot and I still managed to hear her crystal clear. Um, let me
Get rid of that if I try to click this
No
Uh, I need to I'll do that
La la la I just want to hold on
Alrighty where is this bridge I don't see it in the fog
It is quite far wait what
Oh, it's over it's down the oh my god, it's down actually
Cool
Impenetrable thorns fascinating
What the fact that I oh, uh, oh cool nice
Everything's nice and cool. Can I hop down again?
I don't think I'll make that. Okay, so that's the bridge right there
The bridge is invisible
Jump off here for a spell
Drain the castle what?
What are you talking about
Oh
Back to the golden hippo. Yeah, yeah
I need a tissue excuse me feel
Oh, sorry Fia. I threw a tissue on you. I did not mean to cover you in tissues
Oh
East door
Spam out spam out spam
How how I should have just ran past these guys. I don't
All right, you know what?
Yeah, we're just gonna run past them because what the fuck is this I'm just gonna waste it
Papa squat
What's the spoopy area?
Okay
No, how what you can come in here
Okay, then come in here then
And I will outrun you
With my talent and skill
Like so whoop-ah whoop-ah
I really can't run uphill can I?
um
I can't look at the map because these motherfuckers
Uh, all right, there's more of them. Ow. I really knew that the guy was gonna jump out
But I thought he was gonna jump straight forward
And this looks like a play second jump from no, it's not
Game is zoomed in a bit you would be correct. Why why why did oh, it's because actually no, I don't know why I did that
There's a ladder
Fuck ladders
I
I'm faster if I run up the stairs
No
Ah
Wrong way too far, uh
Uh
Backward the militia guys are over here
There's a ladder I don't see a ladder
Oh my god, there's so many
What is happening
Make it stop
Hiring
Jump opposite where I jumped so not on this side on this side
Ah reina you're pulling my headphones down. Oh wait. I think I see it
Yippie
Nice. Oh, it's wet. Uh, I'm assuming I can't step off, right?
Um, I cannot cannot see. Oh, that's cool. We got a little waterfall. I'm gonna keep exploring around the edge
Nope, that's not what I meant. I did not mean to press the roll button
I
Did not mean to roll
I blame reina if you could see how reina is on my lap right now, you'd be like, okay
Understandable. She's pulling down my headphones. She's leaning against my hands
I'm gonna blame her
No
Can you sit down lady you're walking all over me
Ah
Oh because he points at the ladder
Oh my god, can I not accidentally step off for the 50th time
I just wanted to look I just want to look around
Is there someone here it's gonna knock me no
Sombra submitting Simone stone
Making my way downtown check the corners the fact that there's no enemies down here is crazy. Okay. That's a dead end. This is nice. Very pretty moat
It's a lot of water. I don't know how our foundations are in this place
I think that we'd have a poor foundation for this castle if there's this much water
That's this deep because this is definitely fed from the sea, you know
Or a lake
I know it's back under the first waterfall. I just wanted to peek am I not allowed to peek
Oh
Hello
No
Nice, okay
There's a paint. Oh wait, I swear. I recall seeing this in some sort of um
Thing and walk through
This wall looks fake. Oh, I was right
I'm smart
Use a shackle to get ahead of the wall
Are you wanting
Too smart the wall just looked freaking weird guys, I'm scared. Well, I don't want to go on a slip and slide
Oh, it's a coffin
Rest in coffin. I'm gonna take a little nappy poo
I am so why am I so tiny?
It's funny because like this is such a bad idea like in a being in a stone coffin in deep water
Just drowning
Getting the coffin she be we're gonna make make mari in it. This is where the fun places. What do you mean?
Why am I so tiny?
I
See like the coffin looks huge suddenly
Spoopy forest this is where the sunflower is
Okay, the music just fucking picked up
Oh pretty
That's how you wake up every morning
Let's turn on the light for you know reasons
What this it's like lava
Oh, it's horn scent
Furnace visage. Oh are there uh, oh
Oh, this is where this place is
Oh, and there's two. Yeah, okay
I want to be super sneaky
There's a lot of golems that one's sleeping
Go touch grass have a good time
Is it gonna wake up even if I'm crouching and creeping towards it?
He's eating
I gotta turn on the golem
Ruins of auntie
Oh, he looks so peace. He's literally sleeping with his mouth open
Oh, baby
Um
Excuse me, sir
I have to move him. I don't want to wake him up. He looks so peaceful. I'm gonna explore a little bit
Yeah, he's just he's just a little he's a big guy. He's just taking a nappy poo
No, it's like a golem graveyard down here
Oh, I guess that's what you get. Oh, um
I kind of wish I saw him wake up
Can you see me?
You can't see me, right?
Uh, I didn't know they could do that
But I'm gonna just back up then
What are you doing?
Oh, yeah, I'm just gonna over here
Oh, I think he's aggroed
Can I summon torrent? I can
I'm just gonna run around the spooky water. There's not another way and I have to wake him up, don't I?
You can throw firepots into them. I didn't know that. What are you doing here? Ow
What are you up to?
Okay, what about this little building over here? It looks like there's a couple of dudes doing dude stuff
Ow, I don't know why you guys keep getting the first hit, but that's just how it is
Wait, so if I
Because I have a hefty
If I throw a hefty firepot will that kill them?
You
Jumping in the back of the building
What are you doing?
Okay, you just kind of keep spamming that do you run out of fp
I
Need several I only have two hefty cracked pots
hefty volcano pot
That
You
Why do you have so many pots, I don't know
You have to tell me I'm waiting for this guy to chill, but it doesn't seem like it wants to
I
Look like I'm just walking on fire
All right torrent
No torrent you mess it up already
Maybe maybe we don't use torrent. Maybe maybe we just do our own thing
Nah, I'm gonna do my own thing. Oh, is he waking up? Oh, no, that's the other guy
I
How good am I at basketball? I'm terrible at basketball. How am I supposed to throw this at him?
Might need to
Oh my god, I don't have a furnace pot
I'm really scared. I don't want to hurt him. He's just sleeping. Can I is there a way that I can
Do it without waking him up
He's just a guy
He's just doing stuff
It has to be furnace did you just look it up it has to be a furnace pot
Because I don't know how to make those
Please please google
Pretend it's a lazy harlot
I'm not feeling aggressive today. I I'm feeling lovey
It's got it does the most damage. I don't even know if I have
Um
Oh, there's a spider. What are you doing? How did where did you even come from?
Spider here you can just crawl in my desk here. You just hang out hang out my goal XLR. I can't deal with you right now
I'm doing stuff
Do it can I jump in?
Can I jump in the head?
No, it just pushed me out
It pushed me out do I have to poke him?
He's not waking up
Oh
Okay, um, well good thing I got a grace for here. Oh, it's so nice and bright
There must be another because that person said he walked he just jumped in I wonder if I can climb him. I don't think I can
Clipping through
Where is the furnace pot? Oh, it's that
I'm gonna see if I can find a way I bet
Um
Because if you don't have that book then they they probably give you an alternative which is jumping
It's in the scorched village. All right, let's just pop over there
It's under the bridge in the gravesite plane what?
Could be found the rundown travelers rest just north and below the okay, so I have to go below this bridge
Wow
Rawr xd no other side. What do you mean other side over here?
Because I would I thought you meant under so I was just gonna run and go over here
On the southwest side of the bridge
Oh like oh, okay. I see what you mean
Wait, why did I go to I'm dumb should have gone to this grace
I
Like how I've achieved nothing so far
Um
Magic tier oh, okay
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh
Let's see what do I need
I
Exceedingly rare to find okay
Um, I'll make two
Is the exit okay, I'm ready to throw pots at ya
Boomi I told you not to go behind there or you're gonna knock it down and look what happened you knocked it down
His back is all bristled
Boomi it's okay
You're okay big man come here you're okay
Oh goofy man
I like leaned up the whiteboard against the wall and I told you know I told I warned boomi not to go behind it
And if you just look so unbothered she's like well, yeah
Let's put that there for now
Boomi gets scared all the time
Because I started to think boomi doesn't boomi speaks perfect English
Because you know I speak to boomi and boomi speaks back
Family which for the cat no, I'm pretty sure when I talk to him he completely understands me
Raina and fia too
But uh
I got your paws
He's a traumatized man believing best see boomi doesn't listen
That's the thing. He doesn't listen
Alrighty wait, hold on. Why am I playing with mouse and keyboard? What am I doing?
At least I have enough pots to like chuck stuff
Um, but I'm gonna die so it doesn't matter too much
Oh my god, torrent, why do you move so fast for no reason like I'm
We're running at a normal speed now, but the moment he gets on like stone. He just like goes too fast
Okay, we're gonna walk torrent walk
Torrent walk
Torrent torrent torrent
Okay ready jump good job torrent jump wonderful
Maybe he speaks Spanish
You got it
Okay, so am I gonna die?
Oh
What the fuh
That's good though. You didn't see me
I can't craft
You guys think I'm fine here. Oh, uh, I'm not I don't uh, I didn't know that could go through stone, but it's fine
Oh nice
So oh you can see me
Ah
Oh my god, what is happening here?
Hi, no, I didn't mean to summon
I
Guys, I don't think I'm doing this right
What is that me yelling who died? Oh, it's my I forgot my spirit ash was out
Can I craft
I gotta score it in the hole. Yeah, but that's hard. Oh look look at him
Can I I can't craft. Hi
What's up, you're so pretty
You have some of my favorite character design in the entire game
Because you can see they're modeled after the fire giants you can see from the stuff on his leg. It looks like the fire giant
How
Can you tell me how that hit me that would be great
I don't like how stuff is clipping through the ground that doesn't
Make quite a lot of sense to me
No, don't move
I can only make one
Can you get down low? Oh man
Can you
It doesn't even matter it's just gonna clip it hit me and kill me
Uh
Uh, what how how my dad?
I'm literally just the just the earthquake itself just kills me that doesn't make any sense
It doesn't make any make a lick a sense
It's
Not a lick
Okay, you just stand in there like what the fuck how she I don't even know how I killed her
I gotta get some more red and inky
I want to just try to eat it in
I want to try
Okay torrent I'm literally de-summoning you and you're not going away torrent, please
Tor torrent
Why can't they get off torrent?
Jesus christ
That like took way longer than I needed to
Well
Yep
Please i'm not ready yet
Oh my god
I'm gonna need those gonna hit me. Oh, they are they ever get that they go towards you
Oh
How does anybody
How does anybody actually what?
I did press the left stick
What
That doesn't I don't that's the only thing I don't like about elderly games
Is that
They you will get blocked by walls anything of yours will be blocked by a wall
But the other enemy?
How do I eat this at his head?
I gotta go what what's happening i'm locked on an accident
Yeah
Are you gonna come in here?
Can I just throw this at you if I can you like bend down?
Can you bend down?
No, I didn't mean kick that didn't say kick rocks
Bend down bend down
I just want to throw something in your head
I think i'm not tall enough
I need him to like start that thing where he bends over and she starts to shoot flames at me. Where are you going?
I generally don't know how anybody like if you're just like fighting them normally on a field
How you would able to be able to eat this into his head. What is up with my foot right now?
All right, well we're we're big stepping
Can you please do that attack?
No, not that one
Please
Oh, yes here it comes. Oh, no it isn't
Oh, uh, oh sweet you killed a lot of people that are nearby apparently
Now
I am five health
How am I still alive?
Please
Is that it is that the attack no it's not
Is it gonna hit me? Oh, it is. Oh, it's over here
You can break their stance
How do you
How do you break their stance?
How the hell do you break one of these stance?
Like I
Six charged heavy attacks. All right, fuck it
I missed
I got him once
Twice
three
four
Five
I'm not gonna make it bros
Six
I don't think this is working
Oh
What did he fall on the fucking building?
I can't
I
He fell forward onto the building
Do you believe this shit Fia
I have to stagger him twice
He doesn't fully stagger off one break
It's easier on a horse. All right, let's try it
Can I lure him over here so he doesn't
Look at this. Oh damn. You see that how my sword just touches the water like that
Oh, okay
Can I hit you
By torrent I was trying to jump at the right time it didn't work
Three times
No, no, never mind. I'm not fucking with the fire golem
Can I like can I like frostbite proc him? Can I throw some can I can I uh
Can I do a little hit him with a one two?
Can I hit him with the with the frostbite for the frostbizzle?
Can I
I'm coming for you, bitch
I'm gonna get you
Just you wait
Uh, just you wait just you just you wait. I was gonna throw it in I was gonna do it
My sword art might count as a heavy
Hmm
He just knelt oh, yeah, I saw us knelt but it's a little bit difficult when you're being shot with fucking flames. How about that?
All right, let's try it
I'm actually gonna kill myself
So, so no
No
I'm done I couldn't quit
Nothing matters anymore
I
Watch me just not speak for the rest of the game
What's in here wow
Something I don't care about um
That's probably a place where you can jump into is that little alcove
I
No, I'm over it. I'm over it. I'm not I'm not fucking with those dudes
It's no point. I'm not good enough. Where's the other one? What the hell? Where's the other one at you walk away?
I'm throw myself off this cliff
Wow
They gave you a grace like this is a very very nice grace of them to give
Really unnecessary grace. Uh, they didn't have to do that, but well not unnecessary, but
I did not know that was there
Can I go down there no
Just fucking threw up on me is your reefing
That's too far
I'm assuming I can loop around
Beeflings with wings ow, can you guys all right well I guess I'll just
Get away from me no
Just kill me
Got a shiver
Uh, wow my rooms. Oh, I needed those
Um, what the heck? Oh
Okay
Well, I bet I can just drop down
I don't I'm not gonna use torrent because torrent will just fucking kill me
Yep. Oh, thank god for that one
I wonder why their graves in the side
Did they ever explain that why are their gravestones on the side of cliffs? Is that is there a lore significance?
Or is this one of the only things in the game that just doesn't have a lore significance?
This is a long way down
Another mausoleum. I haven't even used any of the mausoleums
Oh, I'm almost there
Oh no, I'm fine
Come at me do it. I'll get you I'll get you
I feel like there's something's gonna come out of the ground and kill me
Yeah, I'm gonna get you a buggy die
What I've always wanted a great dragonfly head. This is nice
There'll be hippos in these parts gotta put on just so I can see where I'm stepping so everybody can see me
Is there a grace down here?
There's gotta be a grace down here. I see the hippo. Where is the grace down here?
Also dead people in the walls
The fact there isn't a grace down here is very surprising
Yes, I know this has got a tree fragments and the hippos
Probably a stake. Okay. I think I did see a stake of America
So I'm not too worried
I
bow
You big no, how did you grab me? I rolled to that. I'm not even in your mouth
Ouch
No, no, not the tree. Hold on. I need to heal. I need to heal. Let me heal
Thank you. No, no
No, no
Why do I still feel like I'm so weak? I don't
I feel like I don't do a lot of damage
Ouch
How the fuck
No, no
No, I'm pressing B. Am I getting like input lag or something?
I'm dead. No, no
But I just feel like I don't do a lot of damage
Please the bios America
Please
Wait, did it let me pick? No
All right. Well, all right. Where is the nearest?
I don't I literally see no gold in that forest
Ah
If I landed in the water would I have lived?
Yeah, I feel it. Yeah, that's what it is. I feel like they just have a lot of hp
I went the wrong way
Water is shallow it seems
Wait, where's the thing that was stepped off? Where's the thing?
No
Buggy, I'm gonna catch you
I should have made that I could have fallen from that height
All right jump attack buggy get caught I missed get come here
Nice
I
Think in the stairs
Dog I think I'm gonna find a grace down here before I fight those because I don't want to have to keep
Oh
Can I sorry I'm looking at chat instead of out looking at where I'm going
Let's find a grace
Because there's no stake America is that the moon
Yes, I hear you hippo is that a bore? Oh
Wait what
Is there
Magic rocks what is something doesn't look right over here
This is a pretty shot wow, it's like I'm in outer space that looks like the Death Star
What does she be doing? I don't know I ask myself that all the time
Why isn't there a stake down here? I don't have to keep jumping down
There's two hippos
Wait, what's that?
Okay
I'm just not good at games today or any day, but especially today, that's all I'll say
That rhymed
Sorry to wake you
What the hell
Where the fuck am I what the hell
What the hell I don't even know where I'm going I'm just going
Oh, all right
We're just uh, we're just zooming I guess I guess we're just going
Um, it's pretty dark
Not that this helps
There must be a grace down here. Let me grab it
In this catacomb
Let me just grab it just so I don't have to worry about
Where the are you kidding me? All right. Well, I'll just grab the grace down here just because
Jesus Christ, I'm getting dizzy. Yeah
I do have new drip
Wait, but there's a shiny thing. Why is it so dark? Why is this a horror game?
I
Guys what the fuck is this
Keep this under my mind. I don't I don't want to keep anything in my mind
Uh-huh, I see you bastard
I
Saw you motherfucker. I saw you I saw you
Trying to
Get me. Oh, I think I needed that one
I think I needed that glove work. No now I want to explore
Why is it so spooky down here I have the shivers
What the it's just black nothing is
Hello
Elden ring the horror game come here. I see two of you
Ow, why do you even jumping on it looks like a like a lizard
I feel like I'm not again. I'm not doing that much damage to you as I was before
Hello, can you see me? Are you sleeping?
Oh
What the hell is this? Oh
Hello, what what it was that what is that? Oh, it's just a guy shooting
What's this
I don't this is turn on the lights. Oh, thank god. What the fuck?
Nice nifty
Cool
Stop
Enough burdo
Friendship is magic
Oh
Why is everything so scary in here?
I'm getting distracted. I just wanted the grace
Oh
She be platformer extraordinaire
Maybe not and what's the point of this?
Can I drop down into that ledge? Oh, I can
Oh
Good medallion
Oh, it's fine. Hi
Where are you backing up? Do I scare you? Is anybody behind me?
I hear like movement and I don't like it. Oh, he left so I'll go this way
He's busy. He had he had to go do stuff. Um, oh that scared me for some reason. Oh, yes go down
I can get a cool armor set in here. Oh nifty. I'm getting dizzy. I need to stop spinning when I'm going down
I'm gonna close my eyes
Okay, I'm here
Hello
I see you
Is there another guy?
Are you gonna jump on me?
Oh, wow, I knew it. I just couldn't see the guy up top
Oh, what is that? Is that ice magic?
Are you this is what I'm talking about. I don't understand how shit can clip through the fucking stones
I
I don't get it
It's oh, okay got you I almost fell
Because it looked like ice because there was like frostiness about it. Hi
Aren't you dead yet
Which way westward man
Why are the cat there's so much stuff in here
No
At least it looks like a fish head or is that supposed to be a dragon head it looks like a fish
Is there anything oh there's a ladder that's something
It's a fingernail
It spawns under me. Oh, it's like the ambush one. Okay, that makes that makes so much more sense than mine. Okay
I'm assuming this guy is up here
What
Uh, I'm a little confused
Is this just a loop around because I don't want to do that yet I must be
I hear a little guy snoozing
I
Why can't I backstab from the side, huh?
Is there another one I feel like I hear something breathing. Oh, it's because it's down there
Nope, nope
I
Dispand our one out of fear
And because sad stuff it's not a loop around well, I should be able to loop around
Are you climbing since when can they climb ladders? All right, I'll sleep for you
Take your time
You
Can climb back up
Oh, there's two of you take your time
Ah
This is funny
Now I feel like I'm the enemy in a game and that's the NPC I mean the um
The main character just like walk up the ladder and I just scare them
Oh
Hello, yes comfy. No
I went the wrong way
Ow, I take a long time to do stuff that's not gonna reach you is it
This is stupid
All right, well
No, I might die down here
What
I'm going more down. I gotta close my eyes
There might be secrets and I might be missing them, but it's making me dizzy
Oh mother
What the hell
Okay
Oh
I am just like sir away for me to get to you
I might just let myself die because then I'd have more flasks
I love my cast time just takes a century
Don't kill him until you lower the platform
Oh, but why can't I just kill him then lower the platform
I
Can't frickin see
Assuming this is the said platform you're talking about lowering
Hello
Pressing why like whatever. Oh, it's bright in here now
Will that hit him
No
Is it because I'm charging the spells that way it's taking so long for me to cast
All right, well, I hope it's still there
Hey, but you got him
It will be gone
Oh, will he be gone? Okay. Nope
Oh, what the fuck? Oh, man
I'm gonna get you right in the fucking dick
I already have like three of these
Step my game is lagging
I think that goes anywhere
Slow mo is a cool mode. Okay, that was from the platform. That's right. So it's another way
It's probably behind him. Yes go behind his platform. I see that wait, but I want to see if anything's over here
What is
It's over here
Do I hear any little bitches?
I hear bitches beyond the wall
Thought that was a ladder
Ah
Something in my nose. Oh, it's funny if it is fell
No, nothing to attack me in here
Big mom sip he's got a big mouth. How do I get back up?
Oh
They're my least favorite under me
I missed no, no not like this
How could this happen to me?
I made my mistake
Yeah
What are you doing?
Are you yelling like boomy
It's a baby
Oh, actually, yeah, the the the poop guys and the these dudes
Wow
Oh
I went the wrong way this actually works out because then I can just how are you not getting hurt by
Why did he run away
I
She be healed
I will in a second that's not healing but you know, it's the effort that counts
Oh
We're going down down
Oh summoning pool. Oh who's in here?
Who's in here is there a st. Am I gonna have to come back down here again and have to outrun them each time?
Okay, well
I
There's a way to cheese him. I've actually seen it. I just forget what it is
And there's a way to cheese him I just totally forget what that is because I remember watching someone fight him
Yeah, the backstab cheese
We swear you guys saying we say nothing
There's something else past him I forgot what it is
Yeah
Actually, I can just run
Oh
What ow
I can't see him
I can't backstab you if you're up against a fucking wall
You're not even that actually I could yeah
Yeah, what the hell is it the spooky sunflower? I forget
Is it a sexy lady
Why are you guys all doing the smug face? Yeah, I'll pet you for strength
Okay, let me I need to kill this guy. Let me two hand
I
Can I get behind you
Oh
Geez
Oh my god
All right, yeah, why don't you teleport so I can heal. Whoa, what the fuck
Not paying attention. I don't know why it's not walking on
Ow big fat man, please
Why is it it's like every time he teleports he loses my lock
Oh
Please
Who are you dudes? Oh
Now
I
Oh
You fucked it up you fucking fuck fuck off
Oh, I didn't see where he teleported to I thought he was behind him still
By the way the large mouth imp that you skipped dropped. Yeah, I already killed him. I already picked that up
I
Don't want to spirit summon. I don't have to
Now it's not paying attention
Why can't I
I
I it's so weird like where I have to be to line up fucking perfectly to backstab his stupid ass
I can do this without spirits or summons. I know I can I already got him halfway
So I know that I can do it by myself
Yep, I didn't I just take a file
Damn it
I
Need to figure out where he stands up
Let me heal these
Why do you have to be against a wall
Oh my god, so silly
Come on dude, I know I can beat his ass
Thank you, don't
Yeah, I wish I wish I could be able to stick a little bit off to the side
It would just teleport me to the spot where I need to be so I can just stab him in the back
I
Know he's like they patched him now. He's up against them all wall more
That has some range to it. I'll tell you that much out. It's a little the stagger fucked me
I
Can you stop
Get get out from behind the fucking wall all for the love of christ
Now
Ow
I'm oh, why are you so annoying?
I like your staff
Oh my god
Oh
Why he loops around I can't get it right
Where the fuck did he go? No, I didn't mean to lock on you. Oh
I
I'll be directly behind him and I still can't do it
I thought I rolled out of the way of that but whatever
You
Can I get like blood proc like what the hell
This motherfucker with this fucking dude. Oh my god
It's it's not a hard boss. I just have to get the backshot timing, right?
I'm determined to beat this with no summons
I have to run over
What oh my god air you fucked it up
Oh stop
Oh
Now I even know where the fuck he went looks like a rune arc
I I am I can't even fucking
At least these are here. No, let me just
I feel like his AI goes up against the wall now
I
Fuck off I can't fucking see oh my god, dude
Oh, I'm trash. I'm so fucking trash
I'm sleepy time is it
I
I don't get it
Can you fucking stop
I literally just might oh my god, I heard the bell and I was like shit. Oh, okay. Well
I
All right, I
Yeah, I need your help calming down and walking in
Yeah, let me your strength
Oh
This weak girl let me your strength off big stretch strength
Now it's an elbow
All right
It's not a difficult boss move set is quite simple you just have to be mindful of the summons and the timing
I already fucked up
Oh, just kill me just kill me just kill me just thank you
Yeah, you're not helping yeah, and you didn't help me yeah, I asked for help. Why don't you help me?
She's parring the licking my hand
Thank you for the nourishing kisses
You
Life bed companion. All right
So
I'm going non-verbal
What
Why I'm right behind you why can't I back stab you
You
Oh my god, you're not a hard boss. Why am I fucking up?
Oh
So
Maybe you know summon this motherfucker
Oh
No
Hey, I'm a little confused
Oh
There he is
I forgot I need to back up off him
I
Not this fucking fire summon
Okay
Oh
So
I wasn't paying attention to my health
Oh
What is it locking on the hell
He is just licking my hand
Oh
Hey
Guys if you keep back seating, I'm literally just gonna
Like oh do this do that. I want to be Tim my way. I am not asking for help
You guys know when I asked for help
And it's directional only or if I'm like oh it was a week two which I know is fire
But I don't really care because I want to get bleed on him now
So
Oh
Yeah
What fuck is he no
Oh
Sometimes I just enjoy brute forcing a boss
And that also helps me improve my dodging ability and my timing
Oh
I'm okay. I'm just gonna I might just let you kill me because I accidentally I was scratching my fucking chin
No, I did that too early
Oh
You made several comments that have been pissing you off. So just just shut up
I'm just trying to I'm just trying to enjoy myself and brute force this boss
And then some of you guys are just saying really irritating annoying stuff and back seating
No, I keep doing it too early
Oh
Oh, I didn't think that would kill me
It's an awful annoying fight because it's a fight that is definitely winnable without ashes
It's literally like I'm strong enough. I just don't have the timing in the skill and that's what's frustrating me
I just like I like brute forcing bosses it's enjoyable for me, but hey if it's not enjoyable for you to watch then
You don't have to stay and watch
Oh
I thought I dodged that I can't see that well because I moved my chair back. Maybe I should just put it back to where it was
I maybe I should close my window because the glare from the window behind my screen is annoying
You
Oh
Why do you have to teleport away when I start wailing on you?
All right time that too late
If I get like rule up on them
I need to back off. Nope
Can you
These summons are annoying
Oh
Can I get up please no
Okay
I
I'm playing too hasty. I'm not I'm not I'm not biding my time and waiting for my shots. I'll be honest with you
Are you gonna yeah
I don't think that was gonna hit me but okay
And then I'm not paying attention to my health bro. Why can't I do this? I just don't understand it
I know I can do this. I know I can
I bet if I did off fucking stream then I'd be fine
I
Okay, oh my camera is not stuck so I was adjusting my headphones. Ah
Yeah
Oh
Let me get behind you or not
Let me heal
No, where did he go? Oh
No
I honestly might do this off stream because beating this guy on stream is actually annoying because
It's just
Yeah, I'm irritated at my chat
Your eye itches
Hi
Rain I can't see past you rain know you're standing on my hand
Oh my god, I
Why does it it like okay, do I need to like turn auto lock on or something?
Raina you're standing on me in a way you're gonna pull out my headphone. I can't hear so
I'm gonna pull out my headphones. I can't hear anything
What am I not behind you am I not?
This fat motherfucker
Raina I can't hear anything
You pulled out my headphones and you're laying on them and you have my arm pinned
This is supposed to be a farming stream and I got fucking distracted
I
Did our two
Can't hear anything so
I feel kind of nauseous
I
Rain is purring in my lap. She's gonna make me start sneezing
I think I might find him a few times on an end stream because I don't really feel like streaming anymore now
Because I'm just irritated and it's not gonna make for a good stream
I
Can I rather just wait until I stream later?
Feel like that shouldn't be
There you go, I can't tell where he is because I also have terrible eyesight in this game
I
I don't think that should have hit me
Uh, thank you me
You're gonna teleport away, I feel like you will after I hit you
So
You have a cool design though, I kind of quite like
Uh
So
I thought the graves would walk some of the shit, but I guess not
I don't have my headphones on I can't hear shit
I feel nauseous I think I'm gonna stop playing
I don't know if I'm motion sick
I'll go have fun with strongy playing a painful so see you guys later